the precisely what you are doing
which is in the inner city itself
pointing out to people that their life
is in their own hands
that they can move themselves forward
that that's how it always happens for
all people everywhere
and that we
the
kiss of death is to keep relying on what
the government can do there's nothing
worse
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living in this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bring you the issues and awareness that
you need to know about the violence on
the south side of chicago but also to
raise as much money as possible to build
a community center on this much-needed
block called o-block it's called o-block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs picked up the oldest name and
start calling it o block well we decided
we like the o
but we're going to change it to
opportunity block
i want to thank fox for giving me the
opportunity every single day to bring to
you rooftop revelations where i share
with you my thoughts viewpoints and
opinions on matters as it relates to
violence in chicago and issues that
we're dealing with across our great
country
for a long time we've had black
conservative intellectuals make the
argument against post-60s liberalism
and the argument for true black power
in the sense that we must seize this
power of our own personal agency
now here i am on the ground trying to
take these principles that black
conservatives like thomas soil and
shelby steele have articulated
and apply them to
everyday people i'm on the grassroots
end of all of this and putting the talk
into action so to speak
as we always see in america
ideas are planted and then the action
usually follows
i'm so happy today
to have a guest
with us to talk about these very
conservative ideas
shelby steele
thank you mr steele for being with us
today how are you
i'm doing well thank you for having me
other than enjoying that nice warm
weather in arizona
it's a blessing to have you with us
you know i i am um everyone knows that i
love thomas soil and i love shelby steel
there's not
a moment that i don't get that i try to
tell people about my affection
uh for both of you and so i'm really
glad to have you with us today and i
want to ask you some some questions that
i have written down because i didn't
want to
miss them and i want to just jump right
in
you grew up and you lived through
uh the 60s
what was the moment
that you woke up to the realities of
post-60s liberalism
which many call the great society
programs
what was that moment
well i suppose um
it happened specifically
uh in the early 1970s i i i um
uh
after the i see 1965 the vote of these
the civil rights in 1964 the civil
rights act as the turning point the
moment when blacks really came into
freedom for the very first time when the
president of the united states signed
the bill
saying in effect yes we've we've abused
these people
and that was wrong
uh america i know no other nation that
has been morally brave enough to do
something like that america did
we as blacks then sort of sort of took
that and and uh
i think we
we sort of thought there was a lot of
power therefore
in
the fact that america had done us so
wrong
and so rather than focus rather than
focus on
on taking ourselves forward at that
moment
we fell into a terrible crap
of of dependency
on the in the very society we just won
freedom from
uh we
we argued that uh
to
take responsibility for moving us ahead
and so we put our energies into black
power and to black this and black
identity
and
liberal politics and liberal in the
government and what the government can
do and
legislation and we always
thought that's our hope that's our
promise
uh in fact what we did was take the fate
our own fate which we had just won
we put it in the hands of other people
and uh that's where i think we made a
mistake
in the 70s the early 70s after i worked
in east st louis i worked in government
programs for a number of years uh and
in the inner cities
uh trying to do what you're doing today
actually doing today
uh and not getting very far
and it occurred to me that we had we had
made this profound mistake
of of asking in a sense other people
protesting
their protest was over with we've won
our point in 1964.
uh but yet we kept on we even we protest
today
uh
protesters will never what would this
done all it can do for us
we now have to take responsibility for
ourselves anyway it was in the i finally
i took a trip to algeria where the black
panthers were in a sense hiding out and
i visited them and i spent some time
with them
and i began to see
the the emptiness of this idea of black
power in some political revolutionary
sense
that what we really had to do was go
back
we were lucky to be in america it was
full of of
didn't mean racism was gone but it meant
that opportunity was everywhere
and we have i believe been literally
stalked by opportunity since the 60s
everywhere in american life people are
trying to give to give us
possibilities opportunities to develop
i thought that's the way to go
precisely what you were doing
which is in the inner city itself
pointing out to people that their life
is in their own hands
that they can move themselves forward
that that's how it always happens for
all people everywhere
and that we
the
kiss of death is to keep relying on what
the government can do there's nothing
worse for us
you know mr steele you know
people call you a a black uh
conservative intellectual uh i know
before the label uh you were a black
militant of sorts um
and i i want to ask you have you really
changed at all are you still the same
guy that believes in this black power so
to speak in the sense that uh we can do
it on our own we don't need to depend on
all of these
apparatuses and government uh to help us
are you the question are you that same
guy
i i feel exactly the same way i have not
changed my values since
i was a little boy and my parents were
involved in the civil rights movement
and so forth i believe this i believe
our fate is in our own hands and and
that that
we have been seduced
by all sorts of forces in the larger
society to put our faith keep putting
put black politics is designed on almost
for no other reason
no other purpose than to put our fate in
other people's hands to keep believing
we don't get a voting rights bill
well can you imagine how disrespectful
that is
to saying that we have to have a a piece
of legislation before we can even we
have enough sense to go down to the
voting booth and vote
uh that that infantilizes us
it it treats us as children it robs us
of any possibility of self-respect
you know we've had this black
conservative intellectual movement you
know for a long time now
and do you think now is a time for
people like me to step up and start
applying these principles i know i've
been doing it for 22 years now
and do you think we need more of us
is that the key to a better future for
black america for people like me to put
our idea to put the ideas that you've
been sharing and ideas that uh thomas
saul have been sharing for years is it
time to put them into action is it time
to apply them
absolutely um
to me that's the that's the test of
everything at this point
we now should know it should be common
knowledge in black and within black
america that the government of the
united states is not our way out
our way out is ourselves
the government can it must enforce the
rights and and so forth in in a
democratic society that do all people
but the government can't teach your
two-year-old child
to read
your three-year-old four-year-old
they can't teach your child
what good manners are
how to love themselves how to appreciate
themselves and yet ask something of
themselves at the same time
mothers and fathers do that
so what we need more mothers and fathers
to be doing that
you're doing that
in your community center
you're exactly you're you're telling
these young people
a good happy life is possible
if you develop yourself or to possess it
put yourself in a position to possess it
that's the hope of black america
not everything else has been tried
it's all failed
you know with that you know when you
think about the black conservative
principles and ideas uh mr steele which
do you feel
is the most relevant uh to communities
like mine at this very moment when you
think about these ideas
you know what what's the most relevant
for us
in this moment in this time in this
season
i think i think one of the most
important things in human life
is parental love for children
love in the sense not in the sense of
just heaping you know kisses and all
that sort of thing
but loving children so that they learn
to appreciate themselves they they like
themselves they take risks in life
they learn they expand they grow
when you when when you a group does that
you look up one day and the whole group
is ahead
the whole group is solid and strong and
able to confront all manner of things
all manner of difficulties
but that that responsibility for
development has to come back to black
americans ourselves
we have to do that
[Music]
the reason i just love what you're doing
is because that's exactly what you're
saying
is we the power for overcoming is within
us
and it's not some complicated
overwhelming thing it's good
old-fashioned love your child and ask
something from them
yeah
well
as always i salute you and i thank you
you know
i'll say again and i say to everybody if
you want to know what black conservatism
is all about
read thomas soul
and shelby steele and you'll walk away
knowing what
what needs to be done i'm trying to live
those principles that you teach and
write about and i want to just say thank
you for being with us again
on another rooftop revelation
well thank you so much for having me
it's indeed
my honor thank you absolutely
i want to thank eli steele for producing
this show i want to thank uh terrell for
filming and of course i am so very
thankful
uh to fox for giving me this platform
they didn't they didn't have to give me
this platform but
they give it to me and i want to say
thank you
god bless you god bless america and
until tomorrow
as i always say another rooftop
revelation
peace
you